[Music]
for
billions of years the sun's
gravitational pull
has kept earth's orbit on a steady
and reliable path but this rogue star
has other plans for our planet
this sudden shift in earth's gravity
would cause our planet
to break away from orbiting the sun and
now
for the first time in our planet's
history we would be drifting through
space without any direction
how fast would earth travel
could we survive the extreme
temperatures of space
and could the earth fly through the
asteroid belt
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if earth went rogue
right now earth is moving away from the
sun
at the rate of 1.5 centimeters
per year but if a rogue star
a star that's not gravitationally bound
to any galaxy
came close enough to our planet the
gravity
exerted by the star might be strong
enough to
nudge earth into a one-way trip
through the universe our planet would
become
a living spaceship hurtling through the
darkness of space with
all humanity as its passengers but
if we kept moving further away from the
sun
how long would our atmosphere last
[Music]
gravity and motion are the unseen forces
that
hold together our existence in this
world
if the earth were stationary the sun's
gravity
would suck our planet right into its
flames
fortunately earth's orbit keeps us safe
from that threat
but if our world was knocked off course
we would travel the galaxy at the same
speed we orbit the sun earth would take
us
on a non-stop flight at 30 kilometers a
second
that's 125 times faster than a jet plane
but what would happen to the moon
because the moon remains tethered to the
earth's gravity
we might have an extra passenger on this
road trip
but that might not be the case for long
we'll talk more about that later as
earth leaves its orbit
our neighbor planet venus would fade
from sight
but we'd be losing more than a view soon
the world would leave our solar system's
habitable zone
this area is the distance from the sun
in which water can exist
as a liquid providing earth with the
building blocks of life but
if something knocked earth out of the
habitable zone
our planet's water supply would begin to
freeze over
we'd have to thaw ice just for a drink
of water
and while our thin atmosphere might
remain
it wouldn't provide us with a buffer
between our planet and
the dark cold of space
and to survive on this rogue planet
you'd need something to fill the gaps in
your diet and
to create a new routine well with ritual
you'll get high quality nutrients in a
vegan friendly multivitamin
this delayed release capsule delivers
nine nutrients recommended by
scientists without any gmos or synthetic
fillers
i got interested in ritual because you
know what you're getting in every
capsule and
every ingredient is transparently
sourced plus
mint flavor am i right and ritual gives
you
methylated forms of vitamins like folate
and b12 so
your body doesn't have to methylate them
yourself
when you sign up for ritual your
multivitamins are delivered to your door
every month with free shipping if you
don't love ritual
cancel within your first month and
they'll refund your first order
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering what if viewers
10 off for the first three months visit
ritual.com
science to start your ritual today after
all
this planet has a long journey ahead and
you're gonna need all the nutrition you
can get to prepare for the
deep freeze coming up after
three months on its new heading earth
would fly by our sister planet
mars we would be getting only 44
of the sunlight we once had unable to
perform photosynthesis
the conversion of light to energy the
plant life on earth's surface
would die out if you want to jump ship
and colonize mars
this would be your last chance you'll
never see mars again
one month after leaving mars behind us
we would arrive
at our first major obstacle the
asteroid belt located between
jupiter and mars this collection of
small
rocky metallic bodies are leftovers from
the creation of the solar system 4.6
billion years ago
the almost two million asteroids
floating in this belt
range in size from a pebble to one
kilometer across and if an asteroid
pounded our planet that could be the end
of
life as we know it in 2013
a space rock from this belt measuring
meters in diameter exploded above russia
it injured over 1 000 people and damaged
thousands of buildings the energy the
explosion released was almost
40 times more destructive than the
nuclear bomb
dropped on hiroshima fortunately the
distance between
asteroids is about one million
kilometers so
if we pass by one asteroid we may not
see another for a while
this tense journey from one end of the
asteroid belt to the other
would last two months and if earth made
it through the belt
intact we would be greeted by the first
gas giant in our galaxy jupiter
as we pass by the gravity exerted by
this gas giant
might be strong enough to steal our moon
the one moon that's protected our home
for billions of years
might become jupiter's 80th companion
we would see the great red spot a storm
twice the size of earth that's been
raging for hundreds of years
but don't stay outside too long admiring
this view
our planet could reach the same
temperature as
the top of jupiter's clouds a staggering
minus 145 degrees celsius
that's because we would only receive 3.6
of the sunlight we had in our natural
orbit
while most of life on earth might be
extinct at this point
underneath the sheet of ice that was
once our oceans
something might be stirring after all
europa one of jupiter's moons is
believed to have
twice as much water as earth does and
it's all below the icy surface microbes
living near hydrothermal vents on the
ocean floor
might be the last living life forms on
our planet
thriving from the chemical energy
released from the earth's core
these microscopic organisms might be
able to survive
earth's new and extreme temperatures
and earth a planet with over 4 billion
years of history
would start a new chapter by surfing
through the universe
but one thing is clear if our planet
were to stop
orbiting the sun the view might be
spectacular but
you wouldn't be around long to enjoy it
of course things could have been worse
like what if a black
neutron star entered our solar system
well that's a story for another
what if